الزمن وحده كفيل باظهار الحقيقه كامله
بشان ما تريده الامارات من سق
فما يماط اللثام عنه بين الحين والاخر
يبدو اكبر من قصه التدخل في اليمن نصره
للشرعيه ودحر للحوثيين فها هو وزير الثروه
السمكيه اليمني يكشف عن معدات اتصال
متطوره تقوم ابو ظبي بادخالها الى
الارخبيل في سياق ما يبدو انه سعي دؤوب
لبناء قاعدتين عسكريتين لا يستبعد ان
تكونا ذاتي طبيعه استخباراتيه يعزز ذلك ان
الامارات ادخلت للمنطقه ايضا خبراء اجانب
وسط تقارير اعلاميه اشارت لتعاون اماراتي
اسرائيلي مر مع التطبيع بين البلدين من
السر الى العلم مثيرا في حد ذاته ردود فعل
ايرانيه هددت بالرد على اي خطوه تمكن
اسرائيل من موطئ قدم في الخليج نناقش بعد
تقرير مريم
ابيش ارخبيل سقطره اليمني من ساحر للعيون
الى مسرح للاجندات العسكريه الخفيه ماذا
يجري من تحركات في الجزر البعيده عن
الحوثيين والقريبه من اطماع اقليميه كانت
مؤجله ما كانت قبل شهور قليله تكهنات
وتسريبات وسيناريوهات محتمله تبدو الان
مخططات يجري تنفيذها كلام وزير الثروه
السمكي اليمني فهد كفاين عبر تغريدات في
حسابه بتويتر نقوس خطر اخر يدق وهل من
مجيب قال ان ابو ظبي ادخلت معدات اتصالات
المتقدمه وغيرها الى المحافظه ضمن حموله
سفينه اماراتيه واتهم الوزير السلطات
الاماراتيه باستقدام اجانب من جنسيات
مختلفه والسماح لهم بدخول المحافظه دون
تاشيرات او اجراءات الدخول المعتاده في
المنافذ الجويه
والبحريه نبه المسؤول اليمني الى الاتفاق
القائم مع السعوديه لانهاء الوضع غير
الطبيعي في سقطره والقاضي بضروره عوده
الاوضاع الى ما قبل زحف المجلس الانتقالي
الجنوبي المدعوم اماراتيا في يونيو الماضي
في الظاهر الغى المجلس الاداره الذاتيه
التي اعلنها ولكنه فعليا هو الذراع المنفذ
وحتى هذه اللحظه لاوامر ابو ظبي في حديب
وغيرها من الجزر والمحافظات الجنوبيه ما
كشف عنه الوزير اليمني يتناغم مع تقارير
سابقه عن وخطوات اماراتيه لانشاء قواعد
عسكريه اختر ما في الامر ان تلك القواعد
بحسب تسريبات ستكون في خدمه اسرائيل
المنتش بتطبيع التاريخي مع الامارات كان
موقع ساوث فرونت الامريكي المتخصص في
الابحاث الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه قد تحدث
نهايه اغسطس الماضي عن مشروع تل ابيب ابو
ظبي في سقطره وفي وقت سابق طالب نائبان
يمنيان استجواب رئيس الحكومه معين عبد
المالك بشان التحركات المثيره للجدل ورد
في تلك الرساله ان ابو ظبي وضعت بالفعل
حجر الاساس لانشاء معسكرين احدهما في
منطقه قطنان والثاني في منطقه زوفل كما
طلبت الرساله حينها الحكومه بتقديم اجوبه
عن تسيير شركه جيت رويل الاماراتيه الخاصه
ست رحلات الى سقطره ضمن الركاب ضباط من
جنسيات مختلفه دخلوا خبيل دون ختم جوازات
سفرهم لماذا القواعد العسكريه
الاستخباراتيه على الطرفين الغربي والشرقي
ترجح مصادر محليه ان تكون مهامها مراقبه
حركه الملاحه البحريه الدوليه والعين على
ايران تحديدا طهران اكدت مرارا في معرض
انتقادها للتطبيع الاماراتي الاسرائيلي
انها لن تقف مكتوفه الايدي تجاه كل ما قد
يهدد امنها القومي من قريب او بعيد اين
سعوديه من كل ذلك بنسختيه لم يغير اتفاق
الرياض شيئا فلم يستطع ردع قوات
الانتقاليه الجنوبي ولا وقف تنفيذ مخططات
الامارات التي تتم بعد الان بالتعاون
والتنسيق مع اسرائيل هل السعوديه تغض
الطرف عما يجري ام غير قادره على فعل شيء
في سقطره تجري اشياء مريبه برعايه ابو ظبي
الى اشعار
اخر اسئله كثيره نطرحها في هذا النقاش
وينضم الينا من لوزان ب سوسر ياسر اليماني
القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي العام
اليمني وم الدوحه الدكتور محمد المختار
الشنقيطي استاذ الاخلاق السياسيه بجامعه
حمد بن خليفه ومن بيروت الكاتب الصحفي
يوسف دياب ابدا بك استاذ يوسف من بيروت
اذا لم يكن هنالك ما يتم اخفائه واذا تم
الزعم بانه الانباء عن قاعده اسرائيليه
اماراتيه في
سقطره هذا زعم غير صحيح فلما لما كل هذا
التكتم على نشاط الامارات في سقطره لما
يدخل اجانب الى سقطره دون ختم ودون جوازات
ودون موافقه الحكومه الشرعيه ولما تقام
اصلا او تلقى المعدات متقدمه تكنولوجيا
الى مثل هذه
الجزيره مساء الخير استاذ زين العابدين لك
وللضيوف
الكرام يعني لا شك ان مساله او المعلومات
التي تتحدث
عن تواجد اسرائيلي مع الامارات في جزيره
سقطره هو يعني يعني امر سبق الاتفاق او
الاعلان عن
الاتفاق الاماراتي الاسرائيلي وانا اعتقد
انه يعني من ضمن الحمله التي تستهدف
الوجود الاماراتي في الجزيره بشكل اساسي
بمخص يعني بناء القواعد ربما يكون هذا
الامر واقعي وينطبق على الاق الاات
الامارات لم تنفي لم لم يتم نفي هذه
الانباء التي جاءت من مواقع متعدده منها
موقع يهودي وهو المنتدى اليهودي في
فرنسا بكل الاحوال نحن منذ ان يعني تابعنا
العمليات التي تحصل في سواء في سقطره او
في المهره او في عدن استاذ زين العابدين
ولا مره يعني كان هناك موقف واضح للامارات
بانها كانت يعني في تدلي بمواقف في اطار
الرد على الاتهامات التي تطالها ولكن يعني
دعني اكون واقعيا بشكل واضح اليوم الوضع
في سقطره هو يشبه كل المواقع التي فيها
ممرات بحريه بالنسبه للتحالف العربي هي
تبقى مساله حيويه واستراتيجيه وانا يعني
اعتقد من خلال لا املك معلومات ولكن من
خلال المراقبه والتحليل اعتقد انه ليس من
السهل للتحالف العربي كما للامارات ان
يتخلى عن مثل هذه النقاط
لانها نح ل نناقش الان التخلي عن هذه
النقاط نحن نناقش الان ما هو الهدف من
الوجود في هذه النقاط ولماذا يتم الزج
باسرائيل يعني ما المصلحه للتحالف من وجود
اسرائيلي في
سوقطره انا نعم انا اقول لك بما خص مساله
اس اسرائيل يعني انا لا املك معلومات وان
كانت هناك بعض المواقع تتحدث عن دور
اسرائيلي في في سقطره ولكن ايضا في
التحليل اقول ربما تكون هناك مصالح
متقاطعه اليوم بما خص التهديد الايراني
الذي بدا يعني تتقاطع المصالح الاماراتيه
والاسرائيليه عنده بمعنى ان يعني اخلاء
هذه المنطقه او خلوها من رقابه حثيثه ربما
يفتح المجال لايران للتسلل الى هذه
المنطقه وللداخل اليمني خصوصا مناطق
الجنوب التي تحررت من الحوثيين ومن الوجود
اليمني تسالني هل هذا الامر يعني مقبول او
مرحب ب انا اعتقد ان اليمنيين هم الذين
يحسمون هذه المساله لكن بكل بكل الاحوال
انا اتوقع يعني ان هذه النقاط الخلافيه
ستكون موضع حسم عندما تشكل الحكومه
اليمنيه الموحده والتي تات تي ترجمه
لاتفاق الرياض الجديد باعتقادي كل هذه
النقاط الخلافيه ستحسم وانا اعتقد ان
اليمنيين سيكون ربما راضيين عن هذا
الاتفاق ياسر الاماني هذه المره التصريح
ياتي ليس مجرد تكهنات كما كان يقال من قبل
الان التصريح من وزير الثروه السمكيه
اليمني يتحدث عن معدات وعن اجانب يدخلون
الى سقطره ماذا تعلم الحكومه اليمنيه عن
هذه التحركات من جانب الامارات ولماذا لا
يعلن كل شيء
اسعد الله مساك اخي الكريم ومساء ضيوفك
الكرام وكل المشاهدين الكرام كلنا يتابع
مجريات الاحداث في محافظه سقراء وما يحصل
من قبل الامارات وما يحصل من قبل السعوديه
اليوم هناك العديد من المعلومات ان بدا
العمل على انشاء قواعد عسكريه واستخبارات
جنوب مطار سقطره على مراه ومسمع من
السعوديه التي تقود التحالف وموافقه
السعوديه يجب ان لا نبر السعوديه مما يحصل
في سقطره ما يحصل في سقطره هو تنسيق بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين الامارات
واسرائيل اسرائيل على الخط ربما يشعروا
انه اسرائيل تواجدها سيحميهم الاحتلال او
السيطره على الاراضي اليمنيه اليوم
اليمنيين بعد ست اعوام من هذه الحرب يعني
اليمنيين تحملوا مراره الحرب ومعاناه
الحرب للحفاظ على سيادتهم للحفاظ على
البلد لكن يبدو ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تمضي قدما في تفكيك ما يسمى
بالشرعيه ابعاد الشرعيه عن المشهد وما
يحصل اليوم سواء في المهره او في سقطره او
في عدن هو برعايه سعوديه وبتمويل سعودي
يجب ان لا نبعد السعوديه مما يحصل في
سقطره ربما سياتي لحظه تاريخيه وسيقف
اليمنيين جميعا لمواجهه السعوديه
والامارات واسرائيل على الاراضي اليمنيه
الاراضي اليمنيه لن يسمح اليمنيين
باستباحة التربه اليمنيه سواء في سقطره او
في المهره واليوم على كل القوه الوطنيه
اليمنيه ان تلتف وعلى الرئيس هادي كذلك
والشرعيه ان يحددوا موقف او يخرجوا لاعلان
استقالتهم وسيتكفل الشعب وسيذهب الشعب
ربما للتحالف مع عبد الملك الحوثي للحفاظ
على ما تبقى من من السياده اليمنيه لا
يوجد خيار امام اليمنيين كل الخيارات
اغلقت تمسك الشعب اليمني بالرئيس هذ تمسك
الشعب اليمني بالشرعيه لكن للاسف رئيس
الحكومه الذي هو معين من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه معين عبد الملك لم يحرك ساكنا في
الفتره الماضيه راينا ابن دغر رئيس
الحكومه السابق عندما تحرك الى سقطره ومنع
اي تواجد اماراتي او سعودي وكان له موقف
مشرف وبعد ذلك تمت اقالته من قبل السعوديه
والامارات نحن اليوم انا اتمنى ان يستوعب
ضيفك الكريم من لبنان ان من ابعد قوات
الشرعيه من من سقطره هي السعوديه
والامارات ومن ابعد السلطه المحليه ومحروس
الذين يمثلون الدوله والشرعيه هي السعوديه
والامارات ماذا يتحدث عن ممرات مائيه هذه
جزيره يمنيه وهناك قوى يمنيه لكن هل تتوقع
سيد سيد ياسر اليماني هل تتوقع ان تكون
هذه الانباء الصحيحه انه الامارات بالفعل
ستجلب اسرائيل الى جزيره سقطره هل هذا
معقول بالفعل معقول وهناك تحرك غير عادي
في سقطره وهناك ناقل معدات خاصه وان
الشرعيه لا تتواجد في الجزيره قوات
الشرعيه لا تتواجد في الجزيره من سيطر على
اسلحه الجيش في سقطره هي الامارات
والسعوديه وهؤلاء الذين يتحدثون بما يسمى
بالمجلس الانتقالي هلا مجموعه من المرتزقه
جاءت بهم الامارات والسعوديه لتنفيذ هذه
الاجنده اذا لماذا استبعدوا قوات الشرعيه
لماذا استبعدوا السلطه المحليه اين مجلس
النواب اجور محمد الم الشنقيطي هل الصوره
الان اصبحت واضحه بما لا يدع مجالا للشك
انه التدخل في سقطره لم يكن ابدا لحمايه
الشرعيه ولم يكن ابدا للحفاظ عليها من
السقوط في يد الحوثي او يد ايران هل هل هل
الانباء التي تحدثت عن وجود اسرائيلي في
سقطره لها من المصدقيه والقوه ما يجعل او
ما يفسر هذا التحرك ال الذي يجري في
سقرا نعم لا شك انها قرائن قويه جدا وانا
اضيف الى ما ذكره ما نقلت نقلتم ونقلته
وسائل الاعلام عن المنتدى اليهودي الفرنسي
وعن الموقف الامريكي ا خبرا اخر وهو مقال
نشره محرر شؤون الشرق الاوسط في صحيفه
جيروسليم بوست الاسرائيليه يوم الساب عشر
من اغسطس الماضي ويدعو فيه بشكل صريح
اسرائيل الى الاهتمام بجمهوريه ارض
الصومال بالتعاون مع الامارات ويربط ذلك
بالعلاقات بينهما وبجز سقطره وبوجود
تركيا في الصومال القاعده العسكريه
التركيه في الصومال اعتقد هنالك قرائن
كثيره تدل على نمط من التفكير جيو
استراتيجي الواضح جدا الذي يدل على ان
الامارات واسرائيل تنسق في موضوع جزيره
سقطره وربما ستنسق ايضا في جيبوتي وفي
جمهوريه ارض الصومال الانفصاليه اعتقد ان
كل هذه القرائ اذا جمعت تدل على مسار واضح
في التف من التفكير ومن التعاون وربما
يكون حتى اعلان العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
بين الطرفين والمجاهره بهذه العلاقات
سيفتح الباب اكثر لهذا النوع من التعاون
ليكون علنيا خصوصا وان التستر على قاعده
عسكريه في جزيره بهذه الاهميه تقع على
تقاطع البحار وكل المستعمرين وكل القوه
الدوليه الصاعده اهتمت بها منذ ايام عن
الج بعيدا عن نقطه اسرائيل يعني ماذا يكشف
ايضا ما يجري في سقطره عن الاعتداء على
على السياده اليمنيه في حد ذاتها لانه
هؤلاء الذين دخلوا حسب حسب تصريح وزير
الثروه السمكيه اليمني هؤلاء الذين دخلوا
الى سقطره من الاجانب لم يحصلوا على اذن
الحكومه الشرعيه اليمنيه ماذا يعني ذلك
لتعامل الامارات والسعوديه مع الشرعيه
اليمنيه لا للاسف الشرعيه اليمنيه اصبحت
في خبر كان يعني هو هم منذ فتره البلدان
يتعاون يتعاملان مع الشرعيه اليمنيه بكثير
من الازدراء والتهميش وعدم الاهتمام يعني
ولم لم يتردد البلدان في قصف القوات
التابعه ل الشرعيه اليمنيه كما نعرف على
ابواب عدن في في اغسطس في نوفمبر الماضي
مثلا الشرعيه اليمنيه لم تعد موجود عمليا
هي حقيقه بقي منها ما يكفي فقط لاضفاء
الصفه القانونيه على شيء من تصرفاته
وتدخلات السعوديه والامارات ولذلك انا
اعتقد بكل اسف لا مستقبله لليمن اذا لم
يكن هنالك نوع من تجديد الشرعيه اليمنيه
واعاده نفخ الروح فيها او حتى التخلي عنها
وبناء عقد اجتماعي جديد يجمع بين الزيديه
والشافعيه وكل مكونات اليمن بروح جديده
تشبه روح ذور سبتمبر في الستينات في اليمن
التي جمعت كل اطيار الشعب اليمني
استاذ دياب يوسف دياب هذه الحركات التي
تجري في سقطره هل السعوديه بعيده عنها هل
لا تعرفها مثلا لانه هنالك صمت سعودي سواء
في ما فعله المجلس الانتقالي من السيطره
على عاصمه الاقليم على عين ومسمع القوات
السعوديه وما يجري الان من ارسال اجانب
الى الى سقطره ما مصلحه السعوديه في ان
يحدث ذلك في مثل هذه
الجزيره يعني لا انا انا استبعد يعني ان
تكون السعوديه غائبه عن المشهد طبعا هي
تعرف بذلك وتنسق بشكل دائم مع الامارات
كون النفوذ الاوسع هو نفوذ ايراني في
سقطره ولكن انا بتقديري اليوم الموقف
الرياض لا يتبلور اليوم على هذه التحركات
التكتيه في هذه المنطقه بل هو يتبلور في
ضوء الاتفاق السياسي الذي تصيغ الاطراف
اليمنيه في الرياض والذي سيترجم بحكومه
حكومه وحده وطنيه كلها تستظل الشرعيه ال
يه وهي التي ستكون مخوله باداره شؤون
اليمن سواء في الجنوب او في المشاكل التي
تتعرض لها في الشمال واستكمال عمليه تحرير
ما تبقى من المناطق من الحوثيين وانا يعني
هنا استغرب هنالك دليل على ذلك يعني هل
هنالك اي دلائل سيد يوسف دياب على ذلك
يعني هنالك حكومه شرعيه بالفعل لم تمكن بل
قصفت على مراه ومسمع من التحالف السعودي
لكن دعني اسال السيد ياسر اليماني ما هي
خيارات الشرعيه الان في اليمن ماذا يمكن
ان
تفعل لا توجد اي خيارات لدى الشرعيه اليوم
بعد كل هذا يعني انتهكت السياده الوطنيه
وانتهكت يعني الموانئ والمطارات ومحافظه
المهره وسقط وعلى مراه اسمع من الشرعيه
يعني لا توجد اي خيارات الا ان تخرج
الشرعيه على الملا امام الشعب اليمني
وتتحدث انها عاجزه وان التحالف ما يسمى
التحالف المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات استخدمت اسم الشرعيه للسيطره
على ط لسيطره على القرار السيادي لتجويع
الشعب اليمني لحصار الشعب اليمني ماذا قدم
للشرعيه طوال ست اعوام من هذه الحرب
ط دكتور محمد المختار الشنقيطي ما هي
انعكس ا اذا ثبت وظهر في في قادم الايام
ان هنالك بالفعل قاعده اسرائيليه في سقطره
متى سيكون انعكاس ذلك اقليميا في في هذه
المنطقه اعتقد سيؤدي الى كثير من مزيد من
التفجير في المنطقه ب للاسف يدل على ان
السعوديه والامارات اصبحت مرتهنين تماما
للاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه وانا اعتقد انه
هذا يشبه قضيه تيران الصنافير بوجه من
الوجوه لانه بيعها للسعوديه معناه تحويل
المضيق دولي وبالتالي فتحه للاسرائيليين
كما نعرف ف وهذا طبعا سيعقد العلاقه ما
بين الدولتين مع القوتين الاقليميين
الكبريين ايران وتركيا وبالتالي مزيد من
التازم في هذا الاقليم بكل اسف شكرا دكتور
دتور محمد المختار الشنقيطي استاذ الاخلاق
السياسيه بجامعه حمد بن خليفه اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا ومن بيروت اشكر ضيفي الكاتب الصحفي
يوسف دياب ومن لوزان ياسر اليماني القيادي
في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي اليمني العام بهذا
نصل لختام هذه الحلقه من الحصاد في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
l